[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 27 avril dernier le
décret d'abolition de l'esclavagé a fêté
ses cent soixante dix ans un décret qui
en 1848 tardera à arrivée en martinique
crayon une révolte sanglante à
saint-pierre jusqu'à ce fameux 22 mai
qui mettra un terme définitif à trois
siècles d esclavage ce square cent
soixante dix ans après les membres de la
société martiniquaise s'interroge encore
alors que nous sommes en pleine
révolution numérique alors très
concrètement est ce que la génération
2.0 va oublier notre histoire ou encore
ou plutôt du mois va-t-elle se battre
avec plus d'armes pour arriver un jour à
une forme de réparation une réparation
concrète une idée encore très récente
pour en débattre ce soir cinq invités
maryse duhamel bonsoir vous êtes membre
du mouvement international pour les
réparations
bonsoir les hommes de reynal bonsoir
vous êtes là ce soir
en votre nom propre vous avez tenu à
vous le préciser oui concernant
opposante que moi bonsoir merci eric
d'aidé bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'association tous créoles
bon c'est pas tout les auditeurs moïse
oudinot vous êtes sociologue également
auteur de l'ouvragé corps noir tête
républicaine le paradoxe antillais
bonsoir et enfin vous alexane ozier
lafontaine
bonsoir mon sort vous êtes et lycéennes
tout jeune membre du mouvement
international pour les réparations
vous avez tout juste 18 ans alex anne et
vous revenez d'un voyage sur l'île de
gorée avec lemire est ce que c'est
est-ce que ce voyage vous a permis de
découvrir une nouvelle facette de l'
esclavage passe est que vous qu'on vous
a peut-être pas enseignée à l'école ou
que vous n'avez peut-être pas pu
découvrir sur internet
oui tout à fait en fait nous habitons
sur une île peuplée par en majorité des
descendants d'africains esclavagisés
mais le fait de vraiment se rendre dans
un lieu d'où nos esclaves nos
descendants de nos ascendants par terre
en fait qu'on se rendre aux antilles ça
m'a vraiment fait prendre conscience du
besoin en fait d'aller jusqu'au bout de
ce combat je devrais déjà en martinique
je vais devoir est de plus en plus et
c'était vraiment le moment pour moi en
fait de faire un voyage comme ça et je
sais que c'est un combat que je vais
tenir toute ma vie quand c'est ce voyage
qui a réveillé ça chez vous ce sont des
recherches sur internet ou si simplement
l'école
l'idée du voyage les recherches sur
internet des lectures que j'ai fait et
des documentaires que j'ai regardé fin
c'est vraiment beaucoup de choses qui
commencent à ressortir à la surface ddd
histoire en fuite
en fait qu'on peut lire grâce aux
réseaux sociaux qui m'ont vraiment
ouvert les yeux et qui m'ont donné envie
de me battre pour les réparations et
quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
au sénégal c'est que la plupart enfin
pratiquement tout le monde en fait tous
les participants du convoi disait que
les réparations c'est important pour la
paix dans le monde et pour une unité
pour la fin des tensions raciales je
suis tout à fait d'accord et c'est pour
ça aussi que je trouve que ce combat est
juste et bout merci alex à nous allons
revenir vers vous guillaume de reynal
bonsecours bonsoir alors je répète
puisque vous avez quand même insisté
vous n'êtes pas ce soit représentants de
la communauté békée vous êtes là ce soir
pour parler en votre nom
mais il faut le reconnaître votre
présence sera pas un plateau pour parler
publiquement de l' esclavage et presque
historique pour nom pourtant sur les
réseaux sociaux
vous êtes très actif vous prenez
publiquement la parole
est-ce que ce soit pour vous c'est aussi
s'est montré que vous mettez à
un terme à une forme plus ou moins deux
sociétés permet ce qu'on a l'habitude de
dire ici que les békés restent fermés
parce qu'entre les baies qui restent
entre eux oui et non quand vous avez un
pour cent de la population vous pouvez
pas vous attendre non plus allé voir
99.5 fois à la télé ou donc c'est
naturel que fait le pont santé à la
population soit représentée à léo propre
pourcentage dans les médias moi ça me
c'est avec un plaisir le nerd je suis là
ce soir parce que je me considère
commenté mickey et que pour pouvoir
avancer que pour pouvoir pour que tout
le monde puisse arriver dans un même
chemin pour le pays il faut qu'on puisse
tous s'entendre avec une histoire
commune connaître l'histoire ne pas
l'oublier mais la vie géré et avancer
merci maryse duhamel l'appel de gorée
pour les réparations que lemire a signé
le 27 avril dernier a eu si on peut dire
un écho assez importants notamment grâce
aux réseaux sociaux puisque beaucoup de
personnes qui ne savaient pas on peut
découvrir un petit peu tout ce que vous
avez fait là bas
alors est ce que vous pensez qu internet
va vous permettre plus ou moins de
d'enrichir votre lutte pour les
réparations
oui un de toute façon internet est un
outil absolument extraordinaire au
niveau de la communication
et c'est un outil dans tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus qu'il faut manier
avec beaucoup de précaution mais c'est
vrai que au niveau de la diffusion sas a
une portée extraordinaire donc forcément
la bonne utilisation d'internet va
permettre à l'ats l'information de
circuler à la conscientisation d'aller
peut-être plus vite puisque
l'information sera beaucoup plus rapide
et puis surtout beaucoup plus important
puisqu'il ya tellement de manière
d'informer via internet avec les blogs
les sites les réseaux sociaux donc c'est
évident qu'internet est un outil qui
peut faire avancer la cause merci eric
d'aider concrètement comment vous vous
allez utiliser internet en tout cas
comment vous utiliser cet outil
numérique pour mener ce que vous
souhaitez que peut-être la
réconciliation en martinique toutes les
façons ne peut pas échapper à cet outil
qu'est internet et les assets et de bien
l'utiliser et de véhiculer les bonnes
informations dessus parce qu'on était
honnête c'est un outil très précieux
mais qui est capable du pire comme du
meilleur
quant à ce titre-là la rencontre de
l'homme avec l'homme
il va passer y passe fatalement par
l'outil internet aujourd'hui l'ère de la
radio c'est quasiment terminé pourquoi
parce qu'on était en net permet
justement d'être en contact direct
d'échangés et dans le temps réel le
pouvoir affirmer au contredire
donc c'est au monde un moyen d'être
ensemble tout en état et par billet donc
de ce point de vue c'est un 10 et
géniale et très important moïse dino est
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui que
l'étude de l' esclavage en tout cas avec
cette question surtout des réparations
c'est quelque chose de récent d'une
certaine manière oui on pourrait dire
que c'est quelque chose de récent il
faut déjà dire que cette histoire là
deux cent soixante dix ans donc soixante
dix ans c'est peu il ya je pense si on
calcule mon père est né en 1915
donc mon grand père a dû connaître
l'esclavagé etc
je construis une bonne partie de la
population martiniquaise doit avoir un
grand parent ou en arrière grands
parents qui a connu d'esclavagé
effectivement c'est pas quelque chose de
récent il ya tout un travail à filer
derrière pour voir comment justement
digérer cette histoire et comment
dépasser ça alors justement nous allons
maintenant rentrer un petit peu plus
dans le fond du sujet avec avec cette
question concernant les réparations par
de réparation mais d'abord quel type de
réparation je me pose la question à vous
maryse duhamel membre du mouvement
international pour les réparations
alors c'est une question qui est assez
qui revient toujours et souvent
elle pose polémique parce qu'on nous
pose réparation symbolique à réparation
financière
on peut pas hollande a dit quoi on va
donner de l'argent et puis c'est tout
mais non c'est un truc pareil c'est pas
possible est alors je tiens a quand même
attiré l'attention de tous ceux qui nous
écoutent sur le fait qu'il ne faut
absolument pas se poser la question de
savoir quel réparation simplement il
faut se poser la question de savoir quel
préjudice et après quand on aura
déterminer le préjudice on va trouver le
moyen de réparer ce préjudice parce que
je tiens à souligner vraiment que dire
que des réparations devraient être
symbolique c'est vraiment se moquer de
nous c'est encore une marque de mépris
ce qui s'est passé pendant 400 ans
n'était pas symbolique
nous l'avons vécu dans notre chère nous
l'avons vécu c'est notre sang qui à
gorges et la terre de martinique de
guadeloupe de toutes les antilles et des
idées d'amérique
c'est notre sueur qui a fait peu de cas
fait pousser les le coton lalalala le
sucre etc
ça n'était une autre sans notre cher
notre notre notre notre tueur n'était
pas symbolique donc posé la question de
réparation symbolique
je trouve que c'est encore un outrage
qu'on nous fait parce que il faut
réfléchir d'abord viser les préjudices
et c'est ce que nous avons fait le
meilleur quand nous avons assigné l'état
français nous avons demandé qu'une
expertise soit mise en place pour déjà
déterminer le préjudice
ensuite on va parler commanderie paris
guillaume de reynal quand on vous parle
des réparations pour vous sa salive au
froid qu'à réactions avez-vous face à la
réaction madame duhamel mais madame
duhamel parle des réparations au niveau
de l'état donc
cette concerne ça ne concerne pas moi
directement
moi je ne suis pas mes ancêtres et je ne
suis pas
donc je ne suis pas responsable de ce
que mes arrière grands parents arrière
grands parents ont pu ont pu faire c'est
vrai que on a la chance d'être en france
pour l'instant et la france est quand
même le seul pays à avoir déclaré la
traiter esclavages comme crime contre
l'humanité
aucun autre pays
l'a fait alors que les premiers
l'esclavagé existe depuis des
millénaires on va dire la traite a
commencé réellement avec les quais
portugais et le brésil dans les années
14 100 m2 mais connaît un peu mieux que
moi les chiffres 414 4 75 je ne sais pas
exactement
c'est vrai que la france et par la fait
après une fois que le 14 avait supprimé
en réduire le coût du tabac un petit peu
dans les antilles et a fait venir donc
de la main d'oeuvre
mais quand on parle de réparation
mémorielle c'est à dire concernant cette
mémoire de l esclavage qui encore une
histoire très très très récente
est ce que vous seriez pour cette
réparation mémorielle ont pas du tout ne
veut pas se marier louis parce que si on
veut être un peuple uni on doit accepter
aussi ce que c'est une personne on fait
même si on n'est pas responsable
directement mais on doit comprendre on
doit écouter et on doit
vont un petit peu ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble pour comme j'ai tout à l'heure
pour digérer un petit peut se passer
mais sans l'oublier se passer de nous
servir à nous tenir debout et avancer
plutôt que regarder derrière et trébuché
sur des roches qu'on n'aurait pas vu
monsieur d'aidé vous vous situez de quel
côté entre madame duhamel si je peux
dire et monsieur de reynal concernant
cette question sur les réparations je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
l'association tous créoles alors la
réparation c'est quelque chose de
fondamental et personnellement j'ai un
profond respect pour nos anciens parce
que la réparation ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on découvre aujourd'hui je
dirais c'est parce que nos arrières
arrières grands parents ont commencé à
chercher la réparation en lui-même et
pour nous mêmes lorsque ils ont ils se
sont battus pour nous amener à la
culture pour nous élever pour nous
obliger à aller à l'école pour augmenter
nos potentiels
ça relève vos mois déjà d'une action
vers les parages mais la réparation
n'est pas ça seulement c'est tout un
processus qui au fil du temps permet de
s'attaquer aux différentes strates du de
la réparation pour les faire les
barrages c'est pas un cube colomina
c'est d'inculquer aux mobiles et on ne
peut pas été averti il faut aller step
by step de manière à arriver à un moment
à un peuple
émancipée qui arrive à regarder des
choses on passait à avancer mais ce jour
on va arriver vers quelque chose de
concret ce quand on parle de réparation
qui reste finalement symbolique souvent
se dit après 170 ans
si c'est quelque chose certains de très
récents les études ces questions mais ce
qu'un jour on pourra parler concrètement
de réparation alex al oui je le pense
parce que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
prennent ce combat très à coeur
et de toute façon en fait face pour moi
c'est une étape obligatoire pour les
antillais pour les descendants daf et
donc je pense en fait
il n'y a pas d'autre solution puisque tu
es qu' on en voit une roche en deux lots
il ya des éclaboussures ya déjà des
choses qui découle d'une action et donc
il y a eu le mal les préjudices qui ont
été faits il y a eu les mêmes effets en
fait
l'esclavagé de la colonisation sur les
descendants d'africains réduits en
esclavage et un jour il y aura les
réparations j'espère que ça se fera au
moins 21e siècle ce que j'ai un peu
d'espoir en l'humanité et un jour on
pourra vraiment avancer ensemble
oui je dis nos pas n'hésitez pas à
réagir
en fait je suis un peu
je m'étais reçu la question de la
réparation on parle de réparation
mémorielle ça veut dire quoi exactement
on parle de réparation symbolique ça
veut dire quoi exactement
on parle de réparation financière lui
pour donner l'argent qui profite à quoi
pour aller où
vous parliez tout à l'heure madame des
préjudices je pense que l'un des
prévenus disent qu'on a subi si une
blessure morale déçu au moral d'une
blessure identique 1 qu'il est on
aujourd'hui de régler et de réparer et
cette réparation elle passe d'abord par
la reconnaissance alors mesuré dans la
bouffe est un acte symbolique mais un
acteur yale et je crois que si beaucoup
arriver à se détacher un petit peu de
leur histoire pas si regarder le monde
tel qu'il se présente on arriverait un
tout petit peu plus mais davantage envie
de dire que cette réparation
elle doit permettre de se retrouver de
retrouver une place originale dans la
société parce que nous sommes dans une
dichotomie sociale originelle quand ça
s'arrête
l'esclave âge on a des gens qui étaient
considérés comme des meubles comme des
choses et ces gens doivent passible de
ce statut au statut de citoyen et tout
le travail qui fait par l'état français
il te travail qui n'a pas permis de
réparer ça qui n'a pas rapprocher les
peuples mais qui les a éloignés qui a
maintenu au travers du processus
d'assimilation qui a maintenu au travers
de l'histoire vous savez la première
réparation pour moi serait que le 27
avril soit une date férié au niveau
national niveau national au niveau
national déjà ce serait déjà un premier
acte qui permettrait comme le 14 juillet
comme le 8 mai lyon il ya des choses à
dire derrière je pense qu'on y arrivera
de permettre enfin que la nation parce
que si on remonte à quelques jours le 10
mai ce cas ce que ce que permet la loi
taubira
si le permettre justement que cette
histoire soit on s'est dit il de cette
manière on va rentrer dans une
réparation de manière à avoir un peuple
équilibré et parler de manière
associative très bien alors nous allons
aller un peu plus loin le 26 et 27
octobre 2016
un colloque scientifique
nationale s'est tenue en martinique des
experts d'afrique des états unis et du
brésil ont présenté des travaux sur
l'impact psychologique de l' esclavage
sur les populations
c'était un colloque présidé par le
professeur émérite de psychiatrie et
d'addictologie et mais charles nicolas
il revient pour nous sur l'une des
premières conséquences de l' esclavage
les images sont signées marc balssa et
le montage joseph williams la première
conséquence de l' esclavage direct c
était la déshumanisation donc des
personnes qui étaient en permanence
humilié considérés comme des bêtes comme
des meubles donc ont dû résister dans
leur tête
maintenir leur humanité
et bien cette résilience qui a commencé
à cette époque et bien le se poursuit de
façon de plus en plus adapté au monde
moderne
et c'est sûr que en effet on espère que
ces tensions se vont s'atténuer
cent soixante dix ans de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
il est vraiment important de commémorer
donc parce que cet anniversaire
parce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
capables de regarder en face
demain nous sommes aujourd'hui capables
de regarder en face
hier c'est parce que nous sommes
capables de regarder en face
l'histoire de l'exclavage que nous
sommes capables de regarder demain c'est
ça le sens de la phrase de césaire et
donc 70 ans c'est en quelque sorte
presque le début de
de relations apaisées mais il faut en
effet mieux connaître et on peut pas
continuer à dire que la page la page est
tournée
sans l'avoir lu marie duhamel
oui je souhaiterais réagir sur les
propos de monsieur de jammes
il règne de woods quadrilingue excusez
moi le monsieur de raynal qui et puis
comme dans monsieur dino disait que dont
la présence était symbolique elle est
effectivement très symbolique parce que
monsieur de reynal nous dit que ça
la caste à laquelle il appartient
représente à peine 1 % de la population
et que si donc tout à fait normal qu'ils
ne soient pas qu'elle ne soit pas sur
représentés dans l'immédiat mais elle
est bien sûr représenté dans le foncier
elle est archi sur-représentés dans
toutes les richesses de la martinique
donc vous allez m'expliquer pourquoi une
caste qui représente moins d'un pour
cent de la population n'est pas
représenté dans l'immédiat mais
représenté partout dans l'économie est
sur représentée dans l'économie ça c'est
un premier point est bien deuxième point
c'est que vous dites je dors inhalent
que vous vos ancêtres
vous n'êtes pas responsable de ce que
vous en faites au fait qu'on ne veut pas
venir vous chercher sur ce que vous
n'avez pas fait mais on peut se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi si vous ne
sentez pas solidaire de vos ancêtres au
niveau de ce qu'ils ont fait pourquoi
vous recevez dans les habitations
pourquoi vous êtes encore en possession
de toutes les fortunes amassées par vos
ancêtres sur l'esclavagé et sur la
traite négrière
ou bien vous rejetez tout ou bien vous
en vous acceptez tout vous ne pouvez pas
dire je n'y suis pour rien dans le crime
mais tout le bénéfice du crime j'en
profite et j'estime qu'il est à moi
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
et c'est en ce sens que je dis que votre
présence est effectivement extrêmement
symbolique parce que vos propos sont
tout à fait représentative de ce que
pense votre caste en général
je veux parler devant ma casse comme
j'ai dit je parle en mon nom propre vous
vous dites corner s'ils ont représenté
économiquement surreprésentés au niveau
des terres
c'était peut-être vrai il ya de
nombreuses années
je pense que maintenant si vous regardez
un petit peu les différents chiffres ça
a beaucoup changé
ça vous que vos lui donc on peut pas
généraliser ce que vous faites en fait
c'est une généralisation pareil de caste
or ce sont des individus qui ne sont pas
qu'il faut traiter en tant que quand
tant qu'individu pas en tant que comme
vous dites de caste ce sont des
habitudes des individus des martiniquais
comme les autres qui ont qui ont passé
un passé commun avec vous on est
logiquement vous et moi ici en
martinique pour pouvoir faire une demain
meilleur justement excusez moi puisqu'on
est sur la notion de peuple martiniquais
et de qu'on parle beaucoup de solidarité
ce soir j'aimerais savoir vous en tant
que descendants d'esclavagistes est-ce
qu'il ya ce que j'ai moi je suis pas
j'ai pas vraiment tous les documents
meilleurs arrières grands parents en
partie excusez moi est ce qui vous est
déjà venu à l'idée en fait par vous même
justement de d'indemniser en fait la
population d'une manière ou d'une autre
personnellement je ne vois pas comment
je peux le faire actuellement
je suis depuis depuis un an au chômage
par exemple j'ai créé une petite société
de conseil tout seul pour essayer de
trous de créer mon propre emploi donc
voyez on est pas tous des milliardaires
comme vous mais moi c'est toujours cette
question de l'indemnisation
moi qui la travaille je suis davantage
que l'individu ses blessures morales que
l'on a subi et qu'il faut réparer parce
que le mécanisme de socialisation de
toute façon nous conduit à une posture à
une position et l'infériorisation c'est
ce que j'essaie d'expliquer dans le
livre et j'essaie de montrer comment on
commet au travers du processus de
socialisation à partir de deux concours
peut reprendre le catéchisme de 1789 de
bouger de lille
on peut reprendre la place du citoyen ce
qui me pose un problème dans tout ça
c'est qu'on parle de beaucoup d'argent
on parle d'argent d'indemnisation bon
siad c'est vrai mais le problème si ça
va ou
mais c'est surtout que mon nous faisons
société comment nous aujourd'hui nous
arrivons à dépasser sans oublier ce qui
s'est passé parce que je ne suis pas en
train de dire qu'il faut passer un trait
sur ce qui s'est passé que les ancêtres
de monsieur de reynal ou autres soient
responsables certes
maintenant est-ce qu'on va jouer à se
bagarrer ou est ce qu'on va essayer de
trouver une position qui nous permettent
d'avancer en même temps sans jamais
oublier cette histoire et en même temps
essayer de retrouver parce qu'il est
vrai qu'il ya des terres qui ont été
prises de manière dont ils sont
propriétaires on se demande comment
parce qu'ils sont arrivés très tard et
c'est bon c'est ainsi qu'en gros
problème aujourd'hui est ce qu'on va
rester toujours sur sap qui de toute
manière nous en pêtre dans quelque chose
ou est ce qu'on va lui dépassé comment
on peut faire pour le débat je pense que
justement on va les dépasser une fois
qu'il y aura une vraie reconnaissance du
crime et donc il y aura eu réparation
c'est comme ça en fait dans tous les cas
d'abus
je dirais dans toutes les situations où
il ya quelqu'un qui s'est fait prendre
quelque chose donc en l'occurrence son
humanité quand même c'est pas rien qu'on
a arraché
à sa terre je pense qu'il est essentiel
en fait qu'il soit reconnu en tant que
victime ne peut pas avancer
s'il n'ya pas de reconnaissance du
statut de victime dont une partie des
martiniquais ont été infligés à un
moment de leur histoire
monsieur parce que il faut il faut
prendre le problème dans dans le bon
sens et c'est pas évident de trouver le
bon sens c'est toute la complexité
il n'y a pas longtemps que l'on commencé
à célébrer l'abolition des très riches
ici je crois pour la fêter sa centième
anniversaire etc n'ont pas fait pas
longtemps mais ce travail il est il est
fondamental et il se fait mais pour
qu'il se fasse il faut qu'on puisse
regarder au bon endroit
je donne mon avis le bon endroit c'est
de chercher la responsabilité de l'état
français depuis l'époque de la royauté
ça part de là il faut commencer par
pointer du doigt et des bons ça a
commencé ou faire commencer par ces gens
là d'accord non la royauté française
pour son époque elle est extrêmement
impliqué dans l'église catholique était
impliqué dans cette affaire et il faut
pouvoir regarder ça et dire voilà l'état
des lieux excusez moi ça n'a pas
vraiment commencé avec la royauté
française en fait au début l'esclavagé
la traite ce n'était pas légal c'est la
royauté française qui s'est emparée du
business on va dire non mais c'est bien
ça il faut qu'on passe à une fois qu'on
a connu tout ça bon endroit a commencé à
faire un travail sur nous mêmes sur nous
mêmes parce que c'est ça qui était pas
longtemps en os en santé d'un patient ne
fait pas un travail sur nous mêmes je
vais vous expliquer tout à l'heure
jusqu'où le système
le schéma le schéma esclavagiste
jusqu'au il arrive aujourd'hui et je ne
veux pas monopoliser les bons mais je
vais vous expliquer jusqu'au ce1 et ce2
et ça peut vous serez édifiés de voir
comment le système de lugano
aujourd'hui tient sur un schéma qui est
à part baptise pas le schéma est un jeu
proche du chemin des chèvres à internet
puisque le schéma internet c'est-à-dire
peu rapidement et quand vous prenez des
ordinateurs en gros nous avons des
ordinateurs j'ai appris ça à l'école
j'ai ça a été ma fonction
vous avez vous dit voilà il ya une ferme
de serveurs une ferme d'ordinateurs donc
c'est un pays à l'intérieur de ça vous
avez des serveurs on connaissait ce
terme sont des serveurs et dans les
serveurs il y aura des serveurs qui sont
des serveurs m le mot déjà donne une
résonance des serveurs maîtres dont m il
ya un serveur qui s'appelle patrick
lemaître de schémas et autour de tout ça
les ordinateurs qui sont autour de vider
comme on les appelle les esclaves les
machines d'esclaves aujourd'hui on est
arrivé avec ce très important ça alors
attendez ça explique le schéma pourquoi
on emploie le terme de ma vie il ya un
domaine trop bien c'est un domaine à la
viande ou de manille 1 m et autour du
maître il ya des esclaves aujourd'hui
comme vous faites des études
informatiques n'ont pas plus le moins ce
club parce qu'on a remarqué que c'était
pas trouvé dit qu'ils nous savons ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que le schéma
seul dans le monde moderne informatique
avec tout ce que sa propre aujourd'hui
google tôt quand vous appuyez sur google
écho bot fait une fonction vous entrez
vous faites appel à des codes qui sont
basés sur un schéma petit 50 qui s'est
appuyé qui s'appuie sur justement ce sur
moi on a été on a été bâtie ici vous
vous rendez compte
donc ça montre qu'il faut aller jusque
là pour comprendre les codes des faits a
ses codes pour commencer à exister nous
mêmes c'est un peu ce que je voulais
dire de réparation je suis en train de
penser que
il ya une discussion forcément à voir je
pense entre eux guy en martinique
vraiment il ya un vrai débat lancé yahya
yahya mais pas que là et il ne faut pas
simplement s'enfermer dessus parce que
si on va un peu plus loin si on va un
peu plus loin sur l'histoire sur notre
histoire si on va un peu plus loin sur
cette réparation
on peut aussi se demander comment en
1902 lors de la deuxième guerre mondiale
par exemple
oui si on va jusqu'à là c'est la
question de la réparation
comment au final quel crédit ont donné
au travail que l'on fait comment
finalement si peuple de martinique se
mettre ensemble pour parler d'une voix
de quelque chose et d'une réparation ou
est ce que je vous disais que il y à il
ya plusieurs schémas il ya des gens qui
vont rester sur la reconnaissance
économique si le droit de le faire
moi je parle d'une principe ou si la
morale c'est la psyché qu'il faut
réparer parce que le mal être que xvi
est un mal être qui est il acceptable de
la société
mais que non même reproduisons aussi le
mal être dont vous parlez en fait et si
on de regret un petit peu l'histoire les
départements français d'amérique donc me
vois loupe martinique
par exemple ils sont tous ont eu en fait
une abolition et non pas c'est à dire
que dans dans l'esprit martiniquais
s'est encore entre guillemets lemaitre
donc le l'état français c'a donné la
libération pense que si on parle de la
date du 27 c'est c'est ça c'est une
abolition ce n'est pas un combat pour
dans tous les autres toutes les autres
villes où il ya eu des combats peau il
n'ya pas être même recherche de
cette difficulté de deux liens on va
dire entre les différentes populations
que la fronde que la france il est vrai
il est vrai que il ya la position de la
france ça c'est une chose mais je crois
que il ya deux choses
il y à la france l'état l'église enfin
il y avait le clergé enfin la royauté de
clergé le tiers état et puis ces choses
mais au-delà de ces deux là parce que il
ne faut pas non plus rien tant se
défausse issus d'états pour ne pas
regarder la responsabilité de personnes
qui ont qu'ils ont pratiqué l'esclavagé
qui se sont enrichis ne faut pas mêler
cela existe encore dans vos côtés et
qu'ils profitent encore à des gens et
est donc moi je n'ai pas je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas de kamal a lancé à votre égard
par contre si on n'y pas d'accord je le
dis je ne dis pas que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord dit que nous sommes d'accord je
dis simplement que effectivement dans le
monde dans lequel nous sommes clients si
c'était au début et à faire il ya cet
état des lieux à faire il ya aussi ce
mea culpa que vous devez faire quand je
dis vous c'est à dire vous et les
générations parce que sinon nous sommes
nous ne sommes pas si vous n'êtes pas
responsable nous ne sommes pas esclave
aujourd'hui mais il y a quand même dans
l'idée de la représentation sociale que
l'on fait l'idée que c'est sous zones
latine et glam oui mais cette je pense
qu'il faut réussira à passer outre bon
on va plus dire qu'il faut la réparation
avant pour vous donner une explication
moi j'ai voulu faire votre politique
il ya quelques années ce qui est une
première aux siens françois où ils sont
les conseils même si j'ai vraiment va
j'ai démissionné parce que chaque fois
que j'avais un mot à dire
des arguments en face c'était je n'ai
pas à parler d'un cas pas de réparation
donc moi j'arrête ça sert à ça serra je
ne vois plus d'intérêt à fait de la
politique peut faire aller travailler
dans une association
je ne savais pas que la commune de
france 2 françoise les préparations
j'apprends c'est bien donc moi ce que je
voulais dire c'est que en tant que
juriste je sais dans le droit français
et ceci explique cela
dans le droit français pour que un crime
pour qu'on en ait fini avec un crime
avec une situation qui a de crime
il faut déjà donc le coupable soit
identifié que la victime soit identifié
que le crime ait cessé que le préjudice
soit identifié et que le préjudice soit
réparé tant que tous ces éléments ne
sont pas réunis
on peut pas réparer réflexion peut pas
réparer le préjudice ion ce qui ne sait
pas qui a commis le crime
si on ne sait pas qui est victime si on
ne sait pas de quoi souffre cette
victime quel est son préjudice
mais comment réparer secret à ces femmes
c'est encore la question attendait quand
on à déterminer qui est le coupable
qui est la victime quel est le préjudice
de la victime
à ce moment là on va pouvoir réparer et
attention et que le crime à la position
que le crime ait cessé
c'est important pourquoi parce que à
lörrach où nous parlons la plus grosse
difficulté pour envisager les
réparations c'est qu'en réalité le crime
se perpétue le crime n'a jamais cessé et
le préjudice lui-même se perpétue il n'a
jamais cessé non plus ils se
transmettent de génération en génération
nous a dit le tribunal de grande
instance de fort-de-france dans un arrêt
d'avril 2014 que le préjudice résultant
des des faits commis lors de l'
esclavage se transmettent de générations
je n'invente rien c'est ce que le cumul
à lahti
le tribunal reconnaît que notre
préjudice n'est pas seulement un
préjudice mémorielle mais c'est un
préjudice que nous recevons et c'est
tellement vrai il avait déjà un petit
peu prophétisé sur l'avs sur le relire 2
le reportage que vous avez montré tout
le lac
d'ailleurs l'ex berjallien de bâcler sur
la vente théologie qui disait la chose
suivante que lorsque on avait on avait
fait des études génétiques et on s'était
rendu compte que certaines situations
extrêmement traumatisantes avait une
influence à pouvait modifier l'adn et on
s'était rendu qu'on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait effectivement chez les afro
descendants dont deux des personnes
déportées et du temps d'esclaves âge il
y avait une modification génétique liée
à l'enfer concentrationnaire dans lequel
leurs ancêtres ont vécu pendant près de
300 enfants nous aujourd'hui
cent soixante dix ans après l'abolition
je vais revenir là dessus tout à l'heure
si on a un moment nous portons dans nos
gênes s'est inscrit dans nos gènes ce
qu'il n'était pas dans les gènes de
l'africain qui a été radié des portes et
donc nous tenons notre situation de
victime
alors maintenant il faut qu'il faut il
faut premièrement que le crime cesse
c'est à dire que ce qui ce kit entérite
et qui n'ont pas hérité de la
responsabilité mais quand hérité des
richesses puissent s'ils ne veulent pas
demander pardon se repentir ils n'ont
rien fait mais qu'il restitue
premièrement et puis surtout il faut que
le crime cesse et le si vous voulez je
vais vous dire quels sont les effets du
crime encore actuellement mais quand on
veut grossir
juriste et le poser la question suivante
est ce que ça ne ça n'est pas une erreur
de de traiter ce problème de manière
juridique au sens de crimes de crimes de
2,2 qui d'amour d'un individu parce que
là il s'agit d'un peuple
il s'agit tout quelque chose de beaucoup
plus massifs avec des conséquences est
décédé séquelles qui sont incalculables
on était quand même reconnu comme crime
a été reconnu comme crime mais lorsque
je veux dire par là je ne parle pas de
dire que c'est parra trinh l'attention
jeudi la partie abordé le problème de
manière juridique telle qu'on la bande
de manière finale en dix ans et elle
décrit un processus en disant il faut
reconnaître il faut il ya tout un
processus
oh j'ai la sensation que ce processus là
risque de nous amener dans une impasse
tellement il ya de choses à dénouer
qu'on y passera mais vit sans en arriver
où est ce le risque terroriste
je vais donner la balle à l exxon
alexane ozier lafontaine
mais vous pensez que rentrer dans des
procédures judiciaires ça va nous
emmener dans une impasse parce que selon
moi en fait c'est le seul moyen de se
faire entendre
est ce que c'est parce que j'ai dit j'ai
dit le processus juridique italie où je
me dis je me dis en fait je me dis
est-ce qu'il faut pas un autre format
juridique qui puisse traiter nos
problèmes aussi importants que le
ramener un problème juridique de crimes
de avec la même méthode que l'individu
que tu es notre individu pour moi je ne
sais pas mais si jamais il n'a jamais
été dit que je n'ai jamais dit que le
crime contre l'humanité commis par la
france est pas relié par les blancs
créoles qui est qui qui se sont
installés dans une colonie française
était un crime d'individus c'était tout
un système
il faut ce que j'espère c'est un système
mais il faut que ce système criminel à
un moment donné qu'il cesse de produire
des effets est ce que je dis c'est que
plus de cent soixante dix ans après
l'abolition
ce système criminel n'a pas cessé de
produire des effets donc on ne peut même
pas encore envisagé de passer aux
réparations réellement il faut d'abord
déjà décortiqué savoir la première chose
reconnaissance ya une loi qui reconnaît
qu'a dit la cour de cassation qu'elle
était mémorielle donc année on peut on
peut on peut l'acheter et ensuite non
mais c'est ça ensuite les la
reconnaissance cadre monsieur jam pas
vous hein monsieur bien je dis bien
monsieur de jaham que québec avait été
invité par pavon l'autre feu monsieur de
jaham j'oublie le nom roger gestion de
l'association tous créoles qui était
venu à une invitation de celette chimie
a ouvert sa ville qui a dit
réconciliables pas de repentance pas de
combien d'ipad europe pas de
reconnaissance pas de repentance et la
régulation la réconciliation et c'est
tout c'est à dire mot on vous a fait ça
vous vous n'avez qu'à vous
puis c'est fini donc ça c'est roger de
jaham n'a pas dit ça du tout qu'est ce
qu'il a dit monsieur d'aidé on va tout à
fait
par rapport à 1990 il a réuni plus de
400 beke en faisant une déclaration
qu'il a faite sur la place du 22ème
auter sa ville où il a des îles à il a
décrit un texte qui s'appelle nous nous
souvenons d'accord où il dit c'est la
première fois qu'on y lit très clément g
le texte que la traite négrière est un
crime contre l'humanité c'était en 1998
d'accord et ce texte a été signé par
plus de 400 béquilles et il a déposé cet
acte en disant voilà mais il n'a jamais
dit il faut pas aider ça s'arrête là ça
sert mais non je j'ai vécu avec ce
bonhomme on en a discuté on sait dès
fois pris la tête sur certains sujets
mais sur ce point là je trouve que
c'était quelqu'un qui avait une vision
qui disaient oui il faut absolument
aller de ce sens et d'un dîner
d'ailleurs j'attends mener l'existence
même de tous créoles a été fait pour
pouvoir essayer de rapprocher de parler
et d'essayer de poser des bases de
travail sur ce sujet allez-y tu veux
réagir
monsieur dorénavent moi moi moi je
je reste encore dessus c'est à dire que
il y a plusieurs choses à mener sur six
c'est important que du point de vue
pénal regarde mais si l'impact
pénalement juridique ou c'est important
mais je dis que ça ne suffit pas ça ne
suffit pas parce que c'est le quotidien
parce que c'est la vie de chaque jour
parce que c'est le commande
celle ci se dit pas oui non mais je
finis en disant que ça ne suffit pas il
pourquoi ça ne suffit pas ça ne suffit
pas parce que du coup ça pourrait être
une chimère en même temps si on ne
s'arrête que sur ça et je pense qu'il y
à d'autres rien roi l'iliade airways qui
sont mis en place et à des
représentations sociales qui sont mises
en place
il y a dit qu'il ya du conditionnement
des jeux jeudi qui a dû constituer de
maurice et jeudi si je suis ce que je
suis en train peu à peu le faire c'est
ce que je suis en train de faire en dix
ans en disant que ça ne suffit pas
simplement parce qu'il y à des actes il
y a des rapports sociaux ordinaire il ya
des manières de faire il ya des manières
de regarder les gens il ya des manières
de considérer les gens et qu'il faut
aussi que l'on travaille le souhait que
non même si on doit regarder ce qu'ils
ont fait on doit aussi regarder ce que
l'on fait mis cent soixante dix ans pour
faire quoi exactement pour aller où
exactement pour dire quoi exactement est
bon pour ça c'est important
matra aussi reconnaître que 170 ans
finalement c'est extrêmement riche en
termes de recherche même sur l'esclavagé
au regard des recherches en tout cas
archéologiques n'ont pu débuter qu'en
1960 et seulement sur quelques parcelles
de la martinique donc nous n'avons que
des écrits pour l'histoire en tout cas
de ce qui se passe en martinique
mais l'avis même des escales on a
connaît ps qu'il n'ya pas encore
énormément de travail à faire pour
peut-être à voir demain une réparation
un peu plus concrète
il ya eu il ya eu une omerta totale sur
sur ce crime pendant des années qui ont
suivi
l'abolition après 1848 il ya eu non
seulement il ya eu une omerta mais
n'oubliez pas quand même qu'il ya eu en
1881 trente ans après 1848 il ya quand
même le code de l'indigénat qui était
qui était pas la france est le seul pays
alors à avoir aboli
certes la france est le seul pays à
avoir reconnu syrte mais l'os la france
est aussi le seul pays à avoir légiféré
en matière d' esclavage et en matière de
traite négrière et il ya d'abord eu deux
ya pas eu un seul code moi il y en a eu
2 2 code noir pour nous dire que nous
n'étions pas des humains et puis il ya
eu après puisque nostalgique de cette
période bénie de l' esclavage
il ya eu le code de l'indigénat qui
distinguait les citoyens français de
souche métropolitaine dizaine dont on
retrouve le même mot ici quand je vous
dis que la situation persiste
les mots ont du sens et des sujets
français qui étaient donc les africains
tous les noirs tous les mails anisé
avant tout les touts les colonisés d'un
des différents territoires sous
domination française dans le monde
donc nous sommes la france a institué
véritablement nous concernant un système
raciste
un système définitivement raciste et
c'est dans ce système raciste que nous
sommes actuellement et j'ai je voulais
vraiment mais vous n'avez pas encore
posé la question 170 autres reconstruire
370 ans alors je dis quoi a justement
parce qu'on n'a peut être pas passé cent
soixante dix a et c il reconstruit parce
que j'oublie à une omerta totale pendant
pratiquement 150 ans et puis ensuite
avec l'épisode 2 du code de l'indigénat
qui attention a été en vigueur jusqu'en
1946 c'est à dire que c'est quand il y
en a eu
ce qui s'est passé avec les nazis qu on
s'est dit bon quand même faudrait
peut-être voir bon ok donc lorsque la
france a institué à ce système nous nous
étions des nous étions déjà en plein
désarroi parce que quand il ya eu la
pollution la france a généreusement doté
la caste blancs créoles blancs et puis
les nerfs on leur a dit écoutez vous
êtes a franchi on leur a dit vous êtes
affranchis et la franchise est un statut
partie
lié dans le droit français la franchise
n'est pas un être humaine n'a pas droit
au respect de sa dignité
les choses sont importants qu'il faut le
dire donc quand on vient me dire que la
france a légiféré moi je veux bien mais
là légiférer et légiférer ou disons
toute l'année j'ai fait comment quand il
a différé jusqu'au bout et donc c'est
important pourquoi parce que ça veut
dire que actuellement on se trouve
encore dans un système où on ne peut
absolument rien reconstruire parce qu'en
réalité il nous faut d'abord détruire ce
système raciste dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure dé mettre partout des esclaves
partout et puis on veut construire sur
sa non il faut péter ce système il faut
le dénoncer
il faut faire rentrer dans les
consciences dans les consciences cole
l'état français à instituer ses rapports
avec nous sur la base du racisme et je
veux surtout les chercheurs mais ce sont
tous les chercheurs et les
anthropologues toutes ces personnes qui
ont aussi cogné a dit le peuple noir
vous savez jusqu'au début du 19e siècle
on a combat est mort ou même encore
maintenant bon il ya quand même combat à
mener pour récemment balbutiements en
tout cas de deux de ses nièces acquis
important que oui mais ce serait quand
même mieux de se mettre ensemble sur
veut faire avancer plutôt que ce m
contre parce qu'autrement ça on est sûr
de couler ou nommer monsieur déjà à
monsieur de la personne ne veut se
mettre avec vous quand vous venez me
dire que vous n'êtes pas responsable de
ce que vous ancêtres ont fait que moi je
vous dis que je pense que le préjudice
de mes ancêtres
comment je peux discuter avec vous ce
sont vos ancêtres qui me qui font que je
porte un préjudice maintenant ce que
vous connaissez mais j'en sais quelle
qu'elle est quelle conversation je peux
qu'elles échangent pervers avec boumsong
et je suis responsable de rien j'ai
toutes les richesses de mes ancêtres
mais ce qui vous ce qu'ils ont pu faire
au vôtre ça me regarde pas moi je porte
dans mes gènes me dit me dit on je pense
que vos ancêtres ont fait aux miens ok
je suppose que vous aussi vous devez
porter dans les veaux ce que vos
enquêtes montfort vous ont fait de vous
sur escaut de même qui a le gène de la
victime je pense qu'il ya le gène du
tortionnaire sûrement je dois je dois
porter ces jeunes là comme vous dites
comme plus tard si vous êtes pour ça que
je suis en face de vous aujourd'hui pour
essayer d'avancer pour discuter pour
pouvoir avancer ensemble
sinon je serais resté chez moi etc
mais moi je pense que ce qui était pour
autant c'est je reconnais est ce que dit
duhamel terme est témoin de ça mais en
fait il faut être pragmatique et il faut
il faut avancer
donc pour ma part tout ce qui est axe
qui permet d'aller vers la réparation
des faits dont il ya des groupes qui se
constitue ceux qui travaillent suez la
réparation mémorielle c'est un travail
ceux qui travaillent sur la réparation
financière
c'est un travail ceux qui travaillent
sur la réparation culturel ce qui permet
sur la réparation économique
c'est un travail qu on ne peut pas être
partout au même endroit donc il est très
important parce que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse moi c'est de pouvoir et ça
c'est ma conviction première et
j'attends cela que simplement au niveau
culturel que les cette histoire de la
traite négrière soit enseignée à tous
les enfants de france
le mandat un sujet si ces fonds la main
d'un moment il faut que ça soit connue
parce que ça commence là j'ai les
bodegas et même sa minutes d'émission se
dit abhorrer et des anciens al-saadi à
gorée je les ai entendus et lundi que la
réparation doit se faire droit se faire
avec nous tous descendants d'esclaves et
descendants d'esclavagistes je ne peux
pas le concevoir sans que tout le monde
s'est tu et j'ai trouvé que ça c'était
très important et très fort parce qu'on
ne peut pas je dois regarder monsieur
doré la suite je ne vous parle pas parce
que vous êtes machin et tant qu'on
n'aura pas déterminer quelles sont les
responsabilités je ne pourrais pas faux
pas allé non je sors je le vois que tim
cook aux mêmes dans lequel nous sommes
venus nous dire deux choses d'abord que
si on doit démonter le système il faut
garder le système de manière générale
applications qu'on a reçu le système
français
le modèle social français nous sommes
c'est nous qui sommes qui sommes et ce
qu'il faisait ou c'est nous qui
regardent déjà nommé abou dhabi
c'est très finir on va revenir vers
malte fils
la question économique est une chose
c'est pas parce qu'on aura de l'argent
que dans nos têtes les chaussons et
parce qu'il faut d'abord il faut d'abord
assez aisément
il faut d'abord il faut d'abord réparer
il faut d'abord répartition doit
demander quelque chose c'est le système
qui nous conduit à ça c'est le système
qui nous mais qui nourrit en confusion
lysiens avec les autres même si on doit
dénoncer et il faut dénoncer et je crois
que en même temps je crois qu'en même
temps le système social dans lequel nous
sommes
et cette situation dans laquelle nous
sommes on ne doit pas se perdre et on
doit mener ce combat là sur tous les
fronts et de dire que la france est
particulièrement responsable de sa wii
dire que l'état est que ceux qui
permettent de construire la société
française et qui conduisent à ça il faut
le dire aussi parce que ce n'est pas que
l'argent qui nous aidera à sortir de la
situation dans laquelle des choses parce
que nous avons des blessures morales qui
vont au delà de cet argent l'argent soit
quelque chose d'important dans la vie
pas du tout je pense que les
considérations morales passe au dessus
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on est plus
dense et à ces jours ci enfin depuis que
les gens commençaient à se questionner
sur l' esclavage vraiment mais je pense
que justement en tant que personnes qui
souhaitent être différenciées en fait de
leur descente en fin de leurs ascendants
plus tôt je pense qu'il serait très
important en fait que qu'ils cessent les
autres méfaits de profiter des richesses
qu'elle esclavage leur a permis
d'amasser d'une différente on est pas on
peut pas se différencier de ses ancêtres
ce que les ancêtres sont là il faut il
ya juste un jugement
l'histoire nous à nous nous montrons
parce qu'il ya une évolution des
mentalités une évolution des cultures
une évolution des connaissances on juge
une période
il ya deux cents ans avec des bases
d'aujourd'hui c'est assez difficile je
pense pour de bon jugement de valeur
avec des notions avec nos connaissances
d'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
s'est passé à 200 ans cistre alors jean
il sait me dis que c'est pratiquement à
la fin de l'émission je te laisse
terminer rapidement alex ajustements
jean il s'est pris il ya deux cents ans
et à 300 en donc justement il ne devrait
plus permettre selon moi aux descendants
des esclavagistes de vivre si bien
qu'ils le font parce que l argent aussi
c'est une preuve de pouvoir et c'est
pour ça en fait que l'immense mickey se
plaignent souvent des béquilles le sait
tous c'est parce que avec cet argent là
il leur montre qu'ils sont encore en
quelque sorte et des lettres
on va juste conclure un mot par personne
parce que là oui on est en train de me
criant l'eau dans l'oreillette que ce
n'est pas possible on y va très
rapidement monsieur d'aider un bon
fonctionnaire
on ne peut changer un système que de
l'intérieur
c'est un principe et la deuxième chose
la rla tous que nous ont pu se retrouver
il faut que l'on puisse se faire mieux
voire de la france c'est à dire mettre
beaucoup plus de respect et surtout
pouvoir nous tourner vers la taille
parce que la caraïbe c'est 45 millions
d'habitants merci madame duhamel oui
alors moi je ne pense pas qu'il faille
se faire mieux voire par la france mais
ce que je crois réellement c'est que et
je crois que la conscientisation
scientiste à sion est de plus en plus
grande à ce niveau là c'est que nous
sommes dans un système qui ne respectent
pas notre dignité humaine un système
raciste qui ne nous respectent pas en
tant que personne humaine et c'est vrai
aussi que la réparation ce sera leur
établissement l'obligation pour la
presse situé là nous nous institué en
tant que personne humaine dans le droit
merci moïse du dino alors je vais je
vais en même temps ça va soulever des
choses moins rapidement oui je j'y vais
je n'ai pour autant de temps que fit
alors je dis quelque chose et je vous le
dis ça s'appelle exhortation comment ne
pas exploser dans une société aussi
perturber votre cupidité votre iniquité
votre méchanceté votre ignorance
exacerbée me font gerber je n'ai rien à
regretter je suis serait sans pitié si
c'est donc de brandir le passé
n'avez-vous pas si river de liberté vous
dites est oubliée du passé pourtant vous
entretuer croyais un autre stupide
fierté vous méprisez dans vos prisons
dorées
il est temps pour vous de vous réveiller
pour moi il est temps de mon année de
continuer à naviguer delavier qui à
paris derrière moi je vous laisse une
traînée ce n'est rien d'autre qu'un six
ans que je vous laisse ni c'est dommage
parce que les dommages à la faille
magnifique je la connais c'est la pluie
c'est dommage si l'hommage pasqua voilà
j'ai ggd a fait rater monsieur de reynal
moi j'avais un petit peu ce que j'ai dit
au début qu'il faut absolument se mettre
ensemble chacun a accepté cet or dans
toutes les communautés discuter ensemble
pour voir un petit peu les réparations
que que le meilleur demande quel type de
réparation réel parce qu'actuellement
tout est un petit peu flou et qui il
réellement est responsable de tout ça
est ce que ce ne sont pas des se sont
pas les békés la caste béké comme vous
appelez c'est pas été français s'était
ainsi c'était un système de l'époque qui
a été utilisée est con avec les
jugements de valeurs actuelles on voit
que c'était quelque chose d'abominable
alexane le mot de la fin
c'est pour vous la génération de ma
génération 2.0 alors eu selon moi il
faut vraiment en fait qu'on ne sommes
pas tous créoles nous sommes tous
martiniquais est selon moi pour avancer
en tant que peuple il faut qu'on se
mettre tous sur un pied d'égalité et
consorts regardant les yeux sérieusement
et qu'on parle d'égal à égal et qu'on
sait qu'on cherche vraiment des
solutions en fait
merci beaucoup à vous tous d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette émission
est passé encore une fois beaucoup
beaucoup trop vite donc on se retrouve
pour le prochain et le dernier résonance
ça sera le 5 juin le dernier de la
saison
en attendant je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée en notre compagnie
bien sûr
[Musique]